-Our next guest
is the editor-in-chief
of "T: The New York Times
Style Magazine"
and the award-winning author
of the celebrated novel
"A Little Life."
Her new novel, "To Paradise,"
was published today.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Hanya Yanagihara.
Hello, Hanya, how are you?
-Hi, Seth. How are you?
Are you still sick?
-I'm still --
I think I'm at the end of it.
I never really had any symptoms.
-Right.
-So ultimately I'm doing great,
and it's just nice to be
in a living room.
-Yeah, it is.
I mean, I was -- You know,
I was saying that
the nice thing about this
is I don't have to worry
about physical coordination.
When I came on your show seven
years ago, the entire time,
all I could think about was,
"Am I gonna fall?"
And I didn't,
so it was a major success,
and now I don't have to
think about that at all.
-That's -- When you left,
all we talked about
was how little you fell.
-[ Laughs ]
Right, right. Right.
It was a major accomplishment
of the night.
-Now, it's very nice
to have you as a guest
for the second time on our show,
especially since you have said
the first time
you were asked on this show
you thought it was
a practical joke.
-Yeah, I mean, it just seemed
like such a horrible idea
to have authors
on a late-night show.
And I have to say
I'm so grateful to you
and, you know,
to your producer, Sarah,
because you guys
gave my book a life.
And I know I don't speak
just for myself,
but for so many other
fiction writers
that you have on the show,
as well.
I mean, this is --
You know, it's hard
to get people to read novels,
and I'm so grateful to you.
It's a real honor to be back.
-Well, I think that
with or without our show,
people were going to read "A
Little Life," your last novel.
Over almost I believe
2 million copies sold worldwide.
And people, you know,
based on your wonderful work,
have a very strong reaction,
a very strong connection
to the book,
and some people have reached
out to you with notes in a way
that maybe is
a little surprising
insofar as how they wanted you
to see their connection to it.
-I mean, people have been
very, very nice,
and it's been such an honor
to get to interact with readers.
It doesn't happen that often,
and so when it does happen,
it really makes my day.
But a few times,
I've gotten these posts,
you know,
on DM over Instagram,
and it'll just be
a picture of a guy --
it's always a guy --
holding a copy of
"A Little Life" over his junk.
And he kind of looks sad.
I don't know what --
I don't know who the audience is
or what the message is.
It never has a message.
It's just the picture.
And I always write back
"Thank you," you know,
because it takes a lot of time
to set up an image like that.
You know, you've got to adjust
the ring lights
and you've got to get the angles
or you've got to get someone
to do it for you, so a lot of,
you know, art direction
has gone into the shot,
and I do appreciate it.
I mean, I often think,
"Is this actually for me
or was this for, you know,
your dating profile
or your writer profile
or whatever?"
But it gets sent to me, and
I am very grateful for it, too.
-That's very -- I think any time
you can connect with your fans
on a one-to-one level...
-That's right.
That's right.
Yeah, yeah. A level.
We're not sure
which level, though.
-Exactly.
This, your new book,
is very different,
and I'm wondering
if you approached it thinking,
"I have to do
something different,"
or if it was just the book
you wanted to write next?
-Yeah, it really was just
the book I wanted to write next.
I think you spend so long
working on a novel --
you know, I spent three years
start to finish
in the actual writing
of this book --
that it has to feel something --
like something that's urgent
and that only you can say,
and it can't be a repeat.
You know, it has to be something
that you really want
to spend time with.
And I think that the reader
also senses
when you're trying
to pander to her
and when you're trying to make
the same kind of experience,
and it almost never works.
I mean, sequels
are very, very hard to do,
and there has to be
a real reason for doing them,
and there wasn't, really,
for "A Little Life."
So it is a very different book,
although I think emotionally
a lot of the themes and motifs
are the same.
-You talk about urgency
and writing about a book
that fits the time.
There is a pandemic element
of this book,
but you began it
before the pandemic.
In a way, you sort of --
I mean, I don't want to say
you predicted it,
but it must have been strange
to work on the book
through a pandemic
having already
started a book about a pandemic.
-Yeah, I mean, listen,
if it had been 400 years ago,
I probably would have been
burned at a stake somewhere,
but I don't have any
particular predictive powers.
And the funny thing was,
you know,
by the time we all got sent home
on March 13th of 2020,
I was so deep into the pandemic
part of this book,
which is the last part
of the book,
that it felt very comforting,
because outside
in the real world
I was a citizen with --
who was just as confused
and scared
and misinformed
as everyone else.
But inside the world
of the book,
I got to do
exactly what I wanted.
I had an ultimate sense
of control,
and it was reassuring in a way
to have a project
that felt
that I had created a world
and that world
was within my grasp,
when, of course, that wasn't
happening in real life at all.
-You know, I think
that naturally people
are gonna draw the parallel
between the pandemic in the book
and the pandemic
we're living through,
but a theme
that I feel resonates
even more for the time
we're living through
is the idea of who gets
to tell our history
and who gets to frame the times
we've lived through.
I mean, we see right now how,
a year ago,
there's this deep fight
about what actually happened,
and you just realize
that people are so thirsty
to tell the story
they want to tell
and make that
the accepted fact.
-Yes.
-Is that something,
as you were writing,
that you felt was going on?
-I mean,
more than the pandemic,
the thing that really
surprised me was that,
as you said, the conversations
that the book has
are the ones that we are now
having in real life
on a much broader scale
than perhaps we ever have.
You know, so, the book is set
in three different versions
of America --
one in 1893, one in 1993,
and one in 2093.
But running through
all of those sections
is the question of,
what is America,
who tells our history,
who's left out of the history.
You know, is America a country
that is great but flawed
and can be fixed
within the systems that exist?
Or is America a country
that is irreparably damaged
and can only be --
You know, it can only be
burnt down and started over?
Or is America
the best it's ever been?
You know, these competing ideas
of what this country is
and how we understand
its history
and who has been
written out of it
and who has been written into it
are questions
and conversations
we're having in schools,
on a policy level,
in journalism,
and amongst friends and family.
And that was not something
that we were having
when I began writing this
in, you know, 2017.
We were having the beginnings
of them,
but we weren't having them
on the scale
we're having them on now.
-I want to ask you
one last question, Hanya.
Because I read this
in an article --
that in college
you were invited to an orgy.
First of all, congratulations.
That never happened to me.
You did not go,
and the reason you didn't go
I find both very relatable
and deeply funny.
Will you please tell everyone
why you turned down
an invitation to a college orgy?
-Well, yes.
I mean, the first thing
I have to say, though,
is, you know,
my boss just wrote me a note
about this profile
in "The New Yorker"
and said, "Good profile."
But you don't want to think
about your boss,
especially when your boss
is the executive editor
of "The New York Times,"
reading about, you know,
your possibly going
to an orgy in college.
But I had these very messy
next-door neighbors,
and they were great people and
they hosted an orgy every year.
But they could not
clean up anything,
so they would let it go for
months and months and months,
and then I would have to
help them clean up.
And I knew if I went, I'd have
to be involved in the cleanup,
so I didn't go.
And, you know, I still
had to do the cleanup anyway,
but that's very relatable,
right?
-It's very forward-thinking
to get invited to an orgy
and just say, "You know what?
This orgy's gonna end
at some point,
and there's gonna be a mess."
-That's right.
It is a real time-cost,
you know, assessment
that you have to make
in the moment.
-Well, I think
you made the right call.
And congratulations
on another wonderful book.
Thanks so much for being here,
Hanya.
-Thank you so much.
Thank you for the honor, Seth.
-"To Paradise" is available
now wherever you buy your books,
but please remember to support
local and
independent bookstores.
We'll be right back.